once my mind committed to it my body
committed Nicki Minaj is opening up
about shedding those lbs I channeled all
of my power and now I have control of it
I have control over how it manifests in
my life the rapper dished on her recent
weight loss during a chat with Queen
radio on Apple musics beats one and she
said the secret to her slim down was
drumroll please um changing her diet I
was trying to come on and die and I kept
on putting it off I really didn't think
I can do it you know I really didn't
think I could start you know having
discipline with my eating habits am i
working out once my mind committed to it
mm-hmm
my body committed okay so nothing
revolutionary or groundbreaking here but
still crazy impressive like I'm a bad
[ __ ] and while Nicki is looking fit and
fierce AF she said she still has little
ways to go I'm still 20 pounds away from
my goal weight hey don't eat old mommy
but she also said right now she's super
focused on self-love no matter what she
looks like I've been talking about that
this year too about being kind to
yourself and and allowing yourself to be
human while at the same time being
motivated and powerful but also treating
yourself as if you love yourself too and
be easy on yourself like nothing and no
one is perfect Nicki Minaj ladies and
gents rapper / motivational speaker
one time I was thinking like you know
what if one of my best friends said the
things that I say to myself about myself
what did you know my the people who love
you don't talk to you like that don't
treat you like that don't say that
things like that to make you feel pain
but we do that to ourselves like women
we do that to ourselves all the time
over our bodies
yes not only is Mickey looking gorgeous
on the outside but she's feeling
gorgeous on the inside too and love it
might have a little something to do with
that thank you
et caught up with Nicki in October 2019
just days before she shared this clip on
Instagram announcing she tied the knot
with Kenneth Petty you teased in August
if we got the marriage certificate so
what's happening we got the marriage
license now I just have to wait until my
pastor that I love comes and does it for
us okay but um the big wedding and all
that stuff that will happen but just not
at this moment and you're going full
bride I need you in a princess dress
yeah I feel like I am wouldn't know so
crazy when I was little I always
imagined you know princess in marriage
and wedding the wedding and now it's
more to me about the life the future to
love the partnership then the wedding
which is so strange because I didn't
expect myself to be one of those people
who didn't care about the lubob cuz I
really don't and he was asking me today
too he was like so you know what are we
gonna do it like cuz you keep on you
know I'm like yeah I just I just kind of
feel like it doesn't mean as much as as
it used to mean because the other part
the real part I haven't
I'm so happy happy and it shows of
course you can count on et to bring you
all the latest on Nikki so make sure to
keep it locked right here until next
time I'm Hallie Stevens I'll see you
soon
[Music]